Yesterday we had kind of touched on the
topic due to the narrator of the Hadith
[Arabic recitation]
anhu.
And we had touched on some of the
history that had occurred during the
time of Muawiyah and most notably
some of the disagreements which occurred
between Muawiyah and Ali ibn Abi Talib
[Arabic recitation]
But Muawiyah was not alone in this
amongst the companions of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
He spearheaded the effort
in order to fulfill the aspect of the
truth that he felt was most correct and
Muawiyah radi
[Arabic recitation]
is not
you know, some small potatoes. Muawiyah
[Arabic recitation]
And
I only mention this because
many of us have heard parts of this
story,
but most of us have misunderstood
most of the parts that we've heard. And
I say this from experience. if I were
to just take a tally on me growing up
and what I've heard from people around
me and the elders in my family and in my
community growing up,
we were taught a very askewed view on
the way
that
the Muslimin are to view and to hold
the difference of opinion which resulted
in infighting and bloodshed amongst the
[Arabic recitation]
The position
of Ahlus Sunnah,
the position of Ahlus Sunnah
is as summarized by by Al-Qahtani
rahimahullah in his Nuniyah,
yaqulu
da'ma jara bayna al-sahabati fil waga
bisuyufihim yawm al taqal jama'ani
[Arabic recitation]
wakilahuma fil hashri marhumani.
He says,
"Do not discuss
and debate
the sides of the issue which occurred
[Arabic recitation]
when it culminated in
actual physical battle."
And he says, rahimahullah, "That
the one
amongst the companions, any of the
companions that was killed during that
disagreement,
he is a companion.
And anyone who killed during that
disagreement is also a companion. That
is their close circle. We're not part of
that. We don't get to judge them. We're
not companions of the prophet Sallallahu
alaihi wasallam.
And
both of them, both sides entirely, every
companion that had anything to do with
the disagreement
or those who refrained from become
involving themselves in the
disagreements, all of the companions
will be forgiven on the day of judgement
because they are between
two
rewards and one reward. As the prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam says in that
Hakim, either just had a fact for a
Sabah for a who
a jar
what either a star
for a who a jar and one word.
He says that if
a judge
tries his best to
to judge with the truth and what is
correct and he makes a judgement and he
is correct in said judgement, he will be
rewarded twofold. And if he is wrong, he
will be rewarded at least one.
And so the companions of Allah and them,
they had this disagreement and it as we
mentioned yesterday,
very simply, if we were to put it very
simply, what happened?
Uthman
and them
was attacked by a group of young
impressionable
men that came from both Iraq and from
Egypt.
And they had very unsavory
origins.
And they had been
inoculated with a kind of
arrogance and anger and hatred towards
[Arabic recitation]
They accused him of being unjust. They
accused him of taking the Khilafah and
making it his own. They accused him of
giving
positions of power to his family
members, right? Nepotism and cronyism.
The question here is
is it wrong? Let's say I was
a
a person of authority, a a person in a
position of power,
right? Is it inherently wrong for me to
make my brother
in a position of power with me? Is that
wrong?
No. When is it wrong?
When that's what put him in that
position. Meaning, he's not qualified
for that position, but I put him in that
position anyways. That is nepotism.
That is what is haram.
But if my family member happens to be
happens to be qualified,
that actually might be better for me to
put him in that position because it is
closer to keeping a harmonious
level-headedness to the government.
So, there's an issue of ijtihad. But
they came and they
resorted Uthman to his house. They
prohibited him from coming out of his
house. They attacked him and those
around him of the companions.
they were armed.
And they kept him in his house for a
number of days, and they finally
murdered him. It it culminated in his
murder.
And it's said that he was murdered just
before the Adhan of Maghrib
while he was reading the Quran.
And
that just before that he had had a
vision and he was over 80 years old at
this point
that he saw the prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam in a in a dream and he
said to him Ya Aba Layla his kunya was
Abu Layla
or Ya Uthman
come and break your fast with us this
evening.
And so he woke up and he started to read
the Quran knowing that his time had come
and as he was hunched over the Quran
sitting on the floor
[Silence]
And so he was killed in this position.
Now
this is not a small thing. The Khalifa
of the Muslimeen has been killed by
Muslims.
And these Muslims were infiltrated these
they were all young men all young
and they were infiltrated
where? At the edges of the Muslim
empire.
Remember we said they came from Egypt
and they came from Iraq, right? Right at
the edges of those two major empires
that were just defeated by Umar
radiyallahu anhu the Romans and the
Persians.
And so
they had confused these young men and
they had gassed them up and sent them
and they got what they wanted
these enemies of Islam that stayed
behind the curtains.
And so
as these men made their way back and the
reason that the other companions didn't
you know
didn't intervene is because Uthman
insisted
that nobody be hurt.
That no even these young men. They're
confused. Leave them.
And so
he chose his blood over
theirs.
Or he we could say he chose their blood
over his. That his blood be shed before
any other Muslim's blood be shed. Now,
how did the Muslimin react to this?
Well, we have Ali ibn Abi Talib radi
[Arabic recitation]
We have
he's not some chump, some guy that just
meandered into the governance of
Ash-Sham.
He was appointed by Umar ibn al-Khattab
[Arabic recitation]
Do you know how hard it would be to be
appointed by Umar ibn al-Khattab? You've
never met anyone that would be
appointed by Umar ibn al-Khattab. Let's
say it that.
Perhaps you and I have never met anyone
that would qualify to be trusted by Umar
to be a governor. And not only was he
entrusted by Umar for 20 years.
But he was in charge of the entire
western front. All of it.
All of it.
Egypt, Ash-Sham, Falastin, al-Urdun,
Yemen,
Oman,
al-Haramain,
Mecca and Medina,
and
Egypt all the way out to Morocco.
They were all under the governance of
[Arabic recitation]
anhu.
This isn't some kid. His opinion matters
and people loved him dearly in Asham.
Now, when he received the news that
Uthman had been killed,
he was very angry and he felt that we
have to act quick
regardless of what Uthman wanted. He
didn't want anybody to be brought to
death for his
on his behalf, but it's not up to
Uthman. We need to take these six boys
or these five boys and they need to be
put to death immediately
in order to show a position of power
and so that these things will be settled
and then
he said to Ali, "If you do that, I will
give you my allegiance."
That's it.
So, he used his allegiance
as leverage to try to force Ali's hand.
Difference of opinion. Ali ibn Abi Talib
felt that these young men were too well
rooted in their communities
and we will lose the allegiance of
entire tribes if we bring these young
men to death now, especially being that
we're divided
and that not everyone has given
allegiance for Ali
to be the Khalifa yet.
And so, if we bring these young men to
death,
we're going to lose the allegiance of
these regions and we're going to have a
mutiny on our hands. That was Ali's
position.
Now, if we were to look at it
analytically, who is more acquainted
with his people,
Ali or Muawiyah?
Meaning in Iraq, Ali. He's
He's more acquainted with them.
But either way, this was the the issue
that happened. They in Siffin. Before
that, they had
a skirmish. It's not really a battle. We
can call it more of a skirmish in
[Arabic recitation]
anha went with
al-Zubayr ibn al-Awwam
and Talhah
and went to speak to Ali and tried to
get retribution for Uthman's blood. They
all agreed
on what needed to happen. They disagreed
on the order in which these things
needed to happen. That's it.
Right? And so, there was fat fighting
and battling. But, when Ali ibn Abi
Talib was assassinated,
Muawiyah was
was attempted to be assassinated on the
same day.
And actually, he was attempted twice to
be assassinated
on the same day at the same time. Radi
[Arabic recitation]
One time, he was attacked with a poison
knife, and another time in salah. Both
times in salah.
[Arabic recitation]
And the idea was to completely get rid
of all of the companions of the prophet
because they were being pushed and they
were being
inoculated, if you will, and
propagandized and radicalized by who?
Does anyone know his name?
Huh?
Abdullah ibn Saba. Yes, a Jewish man.
Abdullah ibn Saba is the grandfather of
the Khawarij, and he's the grandfather
of the Rafidah, the Shia who later
turned into a Rafidah
once they became more radical.
And Sheikh al-Islam compares him to
Paul from the Christians. You know Paul?
You know the story of Paul? He wrote
most of the books in the New Testament.
He was a Jew who specialized in killing
Jews and killing Christians.
He was a Jew who specialized
in killing Christians. Okay, so imagine
Hitler but for the Christians.
And then suddenly on his way to
Damascus, he sees
you know, what he says is Isa
and he says, "Why do you kick against
the pricks?" Blah, blah, blah. Oh, he
has a change of heart. Now he is the
greatest Christian that
ever walked the earth. And so he wrote a
bunch of books and added them to the New
Testament. Could you imagine?
Could you imagine if Hitler in World War
II
say 1944, 1945 just before the fall
of Berlin, he said, "You know what?
I saw Moses on the path on the way to
Berlin. And he said, 'Why do you kick
against the pricks? I now love the Jews
and here's a bunch of new books that I
wrote that God inspired me. Add them to
the Torah.' Could you imagine? Right?
That that's exactly what happened. So
Sheikh ul-Islam tells us that Abdullah
ibn Saba
is the Paul of this ummah. He's the one
that started these two radical groups
and and
funny enough, these two radical groups,
the Khawarij and the Rafidah, they are
two opposites.
But they are two sides of the same coin.
And it's said that Ali ibn Abi Talib put
him to death during his life and it's
said that he escaped to Persia before he
was able to be brought to justice.
Muawiyah radiyallahu anhu, Abu
Abdurrahman,
he does not have a completely white
past. Has he made mistakes? Yes, the
scholars have pointed those out. There
is no companion who has not made
individual mistakes. He doesn't exist.
And Muawiyah
was in a very precarious situation and
he was dealing with a very different
political climate.
And so it is considered unanimous
amongst the scholars of Islam that
insulting Muawiyah is an innovation in
Islam.
Muawiyah
passed away in the year 60 after Hijrah.
And as we mentioned he is the first king
of the Muslimin and there are many
narrations regarding his virtues.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]